tels des pop stars les français sont
attendus par tout sur leur passage
cette fois c'est à côté de béthune
qu'ils sont venus prendre leurs
quartiers sous haute sécurité veille de
match comme à l'accoutumée les visages
sont fermés car c'est demain que les
choses sérieuses commencent
douce france mercredi les bleus avaient
vue sur les vignes du beaujolais cette
fois de leur fenêtre ils apercevront les
champs de blé du nord habitué au château
relais les bleus ne seront sûrement pas
déçu dans cet établissement situé à côté
de béthune qui porte un joli nom et qui
nous donne envie de crier à la veille de
ce match france à la chartreuse du val
saint esprit es tu là on est sûrement
encore plus conquérant que le pont
premier match contre l'afrique du sud
encore plus de conviction pull de jeu
spa de confiance fort et de confiance
pour ne plus jamais voir ceci des
paraguayens en joie il faudra demain
contourner leur bonne défense et se
méfier de leurs très bonnes contre
attaques
nous sommes bien entendu très avertis de
la rapidité de la vélocité et de la
manière dont opère cette équipe du
paraguay
mais on a aussi besoin notamment dans
les moments un peu difficiles comme je
dis on va sûrement nous connaître
d'avoir le public derrière nous parce
que c'est
c'est vraiment une aide précieuse
mentalement et puis surtout pour
adversaire sa tendance à aller faire
perdre un peu la force des jambes
pas d'inquiétude beach et ils seront
bien présents demain les supporters
puissent qu'ils étaient déjà là
aujourd'hui sous la pluie pendant
plusieurs heures à guetter un signe une
silhouette ou tout simplement le car qui
emmène les joueurs vers un entraînement
fermée au public les gens du nord ne
sont pas rancuniers et les lensois
viendront faire honneur à leur
réputation de main de meilleur public de
france
à